et
l'automne dernier la grève du cn et la
pénurie de propane nous a fait prendre
conscience que l'agriculture était très
dépendante de ce combustible fossile
entre autres pour faire sécher le maïs
pourtant certains agriculteurs se passe
de produits pétroliers et font sécher
leurs récoltes de manière naturelle
zoom sur les cribles à maïs
[Musique]
des murailles jaune face au vent depuis
des décennies elles servent à faire
sécher le maïs même en hiver ses
séchoirs qu'on appelle aussi des crimes
ont poussé surtout dans la région de
saint-hyacinthe
au québec c'est d'abord ici qu'on a
cultivé du maïs à saint bernard de
michaudville dominique archambault et
stéphane chaume ont repris la ferme que
leur père avait fondé dans les années 70
oui c'est une histoire de famille chez
nos parents qui ont bâti ce qui est
blanc la première partie date de 1978
d'ailleurs c'est gravé dans le plancher
la date
et puis il y en a au nom aussi l'autre
l'arc ribes est l'un des plus longs au
québec
il mesure quatre cent cinquante mètres
et peut contenir 1200 tonnes de maïs
dont paraît en bottes ça dans un but
purement économique
c'est une façon de faire ça chez le maïs
moins dispendieuse que ainsi l'os
hachoir avec un crime
pas besoin de combustible une dépense
importante pour les producteurs de maïs
car si dans certains états américains le
climat très sec permet de récolter du
maïs qui nécessite peu de séchage
ici c'est une autre histoire pour qu ils
se conservent tous le maïs grain récolté
au québec doit être séchées nos parts et
visuellement va voir comment ces sept
mètres de haut
la plus vieille partie de notre cri
benaïssa a été bâti en 1978 donc ce sont
passés au niveau gestion ça fait
longtemps qu'ils aient payé payé
rentabiliser cette portion louvre est
encore bonne pour quelques années quand
même assez impressionnant
la structure qui peut être de bois ou de
métal est conçu pour maximiser la
circulation de l'air orienté face aux
vents dominants
elle ne doit jamais dépasser un mètre et
demi de largeur se veut un taux
d'humidité qui est qui dessin efficace
mais ça près du vert ce après le moins
de points possible
bien choisir sa variété de maïs hybride
est donc primordial si le domaine de
stéphane qui est agronome de formation
le choix libre et des hyper important
parce que premièrement ce après un hiver
qui sait plus bien ce qu'on parle que ça
simplement il faut que les spas sont en
phase aller plein d'espoir pour qui ça a
l'air bien naturellement comme ça et on
veut le moins de points possibles dans
le crime pas sa pareille flair de
pénétrer de bien faire sécher le lien
et qui dit crise dit machinerie bien
spécifique pour récolter des épis entier
on ne se sert pas d'une
moissonneuse-batteuse mais d'une caste
anaïs la différence entre une course aux
as maïs une moisson moeurs et la corse
on va traiter un hippie on va enlever
ses iphone puis on va essayer de le
garder intact plus possible jusqu'à la
sortie dans la remorque pour notre sa
charge en équipe parce qu'une
moissonneuse on voit tout de suite tout
de suite égrainé et sortir les matières
étrangères allaient à l'extérieur de la
machine puis on va avoir un grain propre
immédiatement pour commercialiser pour
faire sécher et va immédiatement et en
plus d'économiser sur le combustible
dominique est convaincu que le séchage
en crise permet de gagner quelques
heures de sommeil
il ya des avantages à sauter dessus mais
le maïs dedans et puis après ça la
journée terminée ça sèche tout seul
noter qu'un séchoir passe par là même
beaucoup dehors la nuit après sa journée
de travail pour ses chutes et saute pas
de moteur pas de moteur électrique pas
de cauroir tapas de mécanique aucun bris
ajouté donc c'est une forme pour sow
[Musique]
le maïs est la plante la plus cultivée
au québec mais le séchage en crib est
aujourd'hui l'exception la
quasi-totalité du maïs est séché au
propane ou au gaz naturel
même dans la région de saint-hyacinthe
les cribles ont très souvent été
remplacés par des séchoirs moderne mais
si plusieurs les abandonne de rance
agriculteurs décide de les adopter à
saint-hugues se trouve la ferme des
jarres adolescents mathieu girard a
participé à la construction de ces
géants de bois
les cribles ont déjà un peu fait de lui
la risée de ses camarades cash à osséja
pour l'agriculture faisait de moi un peu
avec les cribles vieilles façons de
faire ses choux du maïs nouvelle
technologie permet de faire mon boulot
en l'an 2000 à la suite du partage de la
ferme laitière du grand père la famille
de mathieu hérite des champs mais pas
des bâtiments de ferme
ses parents se demande alors comment
faire sécher leurs mille tonnes de maïs
france la mère de mathieu se souvient de
la réflexion à l'époque étant donné
qu'on faisait partie d'un groupe conseil
on connaissait les prix moyen de séchage
à la tonne donc on faisait un petit
multiplication c'est pas facile
l'amortissement de la structure se
faisait rapidement
et puis après ça c'était au dire de
l'argent neuf dans nos poches hamilton à
25 pièces latence est un tueur 25000 par
anaky qui reste dans nos poches bâtir
des séchoirs de bois était alors loin
d'être la norme mais la famille n'a
jamais regretté son choix ça s'adapte
super bien et puis on va chercher le
maximum d'amateurs en termes économiques
pires en termes de production afin de
réduire les coûts de combustible les
agriculteurs qui font sécher leur gré en
silo laisse le maïs le plus longtemps
possible
on chante pour que son taux d'humidité
baisse mais quand la saison avance les
conditions deviennent souvent difficile
pour le passage de la machinerie dans le
crib c'est le vent une énergie gratuite
qui sèche le maïs les producteurs ont
donc le loisir d'entrer au chant
quelques semaines plus tôt et de
récolter un regret plus humide en
avantage pour le sol pourra commencer
plus tôt car mais aussi choisi un petit
peu plus la fenêtre des récoltes cac on
est coincé dans le thème est la journée
qui fait soleil même si on est dans la
boîte mais on va y aller parce que si on
prend un petit peu plus tôt on peut
réparer nos campagnes de récolte sur un
peu plus long ça nous permet d fois de
choisir un peu plus nos conditions de
chiens l'état du terrain on veut qu'il
soit immense pour parfaire de confection
d'engins
on sait que la compaction laisser faire
la nature pour sécher le grain ça peut
sembler tout simple pourtant cette façon
de faire bien avec son lot de défis l'un
des plus important c'est la machinerie
les cas ce
existe sur le marché mais elles sont
beaucoup plus rares que les
moissonneuses batteuses celle de
stéphane et dominique date du milieu des
années 90 honnêtement on leur construit
quelquefois je la connais pas mal par
cas on leur construit parce qu'on n'a
pas le choix le mandat n'est si on veut
la faire durer il faut former un petit
peu d'énergie dessus
l'abandon des crimes par de nombreux
producteurs ne pas aider à renouveler le
parc de machinerie enseignant en
mécanique agricole au cégep de
saint-hyacinthe
dominique ne compte plus ses heures au
garage on a essayé de la rénover là on
la répare on l'a on accède à bichonner
le le plus complot pour la conserver
aujourd'hui c'est jour de récolte pour
les girard cette casse ou jamais' c'est
la grande fierté de mathieu ici des bris
mécaniques à répétition ont forcé les
giard à prendre les grands moyens
en 2006 ils ont importé une machine de
france l'une des rares du genre en
amérique du nord
mais même avec cet engin la récolte
demande de la patience sont compare
notre corps solide avec une moissonneuse
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est pour moitié
moins efficace qu lagos - sont heureuses
mais pas loin non marchand cirage notre
casseuse lui les moissonneuses son temps
à 812 le débit châtié différent c'est
certain les agriculteurs qui utilisent
les cribles passe donc plus de temps au
volant de leur machine nous une bonne
journée avec notre corps sont onze
lances une 250 tonnes sec convoi
rentrait puis benoît sonnet ce battle
on peut parler de ce en attendant
l'heure c'est que ça peut battre la
technologie et l'eau c'est juste qu'ils
aient pour la version ex large il n'y a
pas de demande de 14 dont vous aurez
quelques chevaux chacun font peau
[Musique]
après plusieurs mois au vent et au
soleil c'est jour de vérité on vide le
crible aujourd'hui on est grande le maïs
non consorts le maïs de ce choix le maïs
a passé l'hiver on est au mois de mai et
puis le mais c'est suffisamment la sec
pour être commercialisé pour vider cet
immense séchoir les camions se relaient
des heures et des heures dans le bruit
et la poussière et là où les crips se
distingue c'est à la qualité du grain au
lieu d'être séché en quelques heures sur
le gaz à feu vif
le maïs de crib est un peu comme un plat
qui aurait mijoter à feu doux pendant
des mois les grains sont presque
toujours de meilleure qualité et cette
année ne fait pas exception s'assèche
naturellement et en amidon vers stocks
d'engrais puis s affiche un gain qui est
beaucoup plus pesant ce grain plus
pesant est très prisé des éleveurs de
veaux et de volaille notamment un grain
pesant et payant on peut aller chercher
de sa 15 $ de plus selon les acheteurs
la tonne saxo c'est un gain substantiel
de cas est aussi au point de vue
mandatant rentabiliser tout stockant sap
londres
quelques semaines plus tard c'est au
tour des gis art de vider leurs crimes à
cette étape aussi il faut être bricoleur
et c'est certainement l'un des freins à
l'adoption de cette technique
les convoyeurs toute la machinerie pour
vider le séchoir ont été conçus sur
mesure par mathieu son père et son frère
la partie de quelque chose qu'elle n'a
qu'une telle amende pour finir avec les
équipements qui donne une très grande
efficacité des opérations
la méthode est peut-être moins rapide
mais elle permet de tout valorisé quand
une moissonneuse batteuse standard
récolte les grains les rafles sont
rejetés au chant ici quand on bat les
épis au printemps rien n'est perdu
l'arabe le coton qui récupèrerait en
arrière de la machine en valeur on peut
en faire du compost faire pousser
certaines cultures comme des champignons
je peux également avec ma la majorité du
temps je prends ma tonne de maïs sur
toujours plus de pièces la tonne parce
que je vais le résident du ndi
pourtant les craybas maïs sont loin
d'être sur une lancée
en fait cette façon de faire est
tellement marginal qu'il n'existe aucune
statistique qui recense son utilisation
alors que l'on tente de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre les
cribles pourrait faire partie de la
solution récoltés et c'est chez le maïs
en crib nécessite 13 fois moins de
carburant sont parle de changement
climatique d'environnement qu'on veut
améliorer les photos ridicules
pourquoi qu'on n'aura pas une subvention
de vote soit un crime sont adéquates de
rang des réserves sur le carbone ult
pour le moment il n'existe aucun
programme spécifique pour les
agriculteurs qui souhaitent se tourner
vers les cribles mais pour certains qui
les ont reçus en héritage la tradition
vaut la peine d'être perpétuer la façon
économique de ces collages et salah et
farfelues ont parlé de crédit en 2020
avec tout cas ce que comme technologique
et pour d'électronique lac d'annecy les
félins au soin du bon dieu qui est celui
qui va le chercher
[Musique]
des séchoirs du genre était déjà
utilisée par les amérindiens bien avant
l'avènement du pétrole aujourd'hui
encore comme à l'époque le vent et le
soleil peuvent être des alliés
à condition d'y mettre un peu de
patience